?
DO YOU THINK THAT MIGHT BE A BIG
STORY?
JOINING ME NOW MOLLIE HEMINGWAY
EDITOR AND CHIEF OF THE
FEDERALIST FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
AS WELL AS HOGAN AGAINLY FORMER
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY AND
DIRECTOR ELECTION INTEGRITY AT
THE AMERICA FIRST POLICY
INSTITUTE.
MOLLIE, NOW, WASN'T THE LAST GUY
IMPEACHED FOR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT, MEDDLING, COLLUDING,
SOMETHING?
WHAT?
>> I WAS NOT A FAN OF THAT LAST
IMPEACHMENT BUT BY THE STANDARDS
SET BY DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA,
THE ARGUMENT WAS THAT DONALD
TRUMP, BY ASKING FOR AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THE NOTORIOUS
CORRUPTION IN UKRAINE THAT DEALS
WITH SOME OF OUR MOST POWERFUL
FAMILIES, AND THAT BECAUSE WE
HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH
UKRAINE, THIS CONSTITUTED A QUID
PRO QUO AND A MEDDLING IN AN
UPCOMING ELECTION.
WELL HERE WE HAVE A LETTER
RELEASED THAT SHOWS THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN EXPLICITLY ASKED
FOR HELP IN THIS ELECTION BY
DELAYING THIS OUTCOME OF CUTTING
BACK ON OIL PRODUCTION.
HE HAS PUBLICLY ANNOUNCED THAT
HE WANTS TO PERSECUTE SAUDI
ARABIA OR PUNISH THEM, YOU KNOW,
THROUGH SOME MEANS, WHETHER IT'S
LEGISLATIVE OR LIMITING ARMS
SALES, AND WE HAVE THIS ALL
PUBLICLY.
AND SO BY THE STANDARDS SET BY
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA, HE
OBVIOUSLY SHOULD BE IMPEACHED
AND HE OBVIOUSLY SHOULD BE
IMMEDIATELY CONVICTED IF YOU'RE
GOING TO BE CONSISTENT.
>> YEAH.
FIRST OF ALL, ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT JOE BIDEN IS ANGRY THAT
SAUDI ARABIA IS NOW TALKING TO
RUSSIA, WELL, IT'S BECAUSE JOE
BIDEN IS COZYING UP TO IRAN.
AND SO IT'S FORCING THEM TO NOT
WORK WITH US ANYMORE ON THE
FIRST END.
SECOND OF ALL, IT'S OBVIOUS FROM
THIS THAT JOE BIDEN DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE'S
PAIN.
HE CARES ABOUT THE DEMOCRATS
POLITICAL PAIN IN THE MIDTERMS
THAT THEY'RE ABOUT TO FACE.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE THE PROBLEMS
FACING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, IT'S
OBVIOUS HIS DOMESTIC POLICY HAS
HURT AMERICAN FAMILIES ALL
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
HIS FOREIGN POLICY IS SO
PROBLEMATIC, OF COURSE WE HAVE
AN ENERGY CRISIS, WE COULD MAKE
ALL OF OUR ENERGY AT HOME.
EVERYONE KNOWS THIS.
AND IF THIS REALLY WAS VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S FAULT, WOULDN'T THAT BE
REASON NUMBER ONE TO GO AHEAD
AND PRODUCE OUR OWN ENERGY SO WE
WOULDN'T HAVE TO RELY ON
DICTATORS AND DESPOTS ALL OVER
THE WORLD?
IT'S SO INSANE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SEE THROUGH IT AND HE'S
GOING TO PAY FOR IT IN NOVEMBER
NO QUESTION.
>> Laura: MOLLIE HE WAS THE
FOREIGN POLICY GENIUS.
DURING THE CAMPAIGN, I KNOW WE
WERE ALL SITTING AROUND TALKING
ABOUT THIS.
THIS GUY, LOOK AT HIS RESUME,
MET WITH WORLD LEADERS, TRAVELED
THE WORLD, DECADES IN
WASHINGTON, HE KNEW THESE
LEADERS, AND TRUMP WAS
SUPPOSEDLY THE AUTOCRAT WHO WAS
GOING TO CAUSE WORLD WAR THREE.
>> WE HEARD THROUGHOUT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND BEFORE HE WAS
ELECTED THAT WE WOULD BE ON THE
BRINK OF NUCLEAR WAR IF HE WAS
ELECTED.
INSTEAD WE HAD PEACE BREAKING
OUT THROUGHOUT THE WORLD, PEACE
BETWEEN SAUDI ARABIA AND OTHER
COUNTRIES A REALLY GOOD FOREIGN
POLICY.
THEN WHEN JOE BIDEN RUNS IN
2020, THE CORPORATE MEDIA DENY A
FOREIGN POLICY DEBATE SO WE
COULDN'T HAVE THE HIGHLIGHTING
OF THIS BUT THEY PROMISED US JOE
BIDEN WOULD GET US RESPECTED ON
THE WORLD STAGE.
INSTEAD WE'RE HAVING TROUBLE
PUTTING TOGETHER A COALITION TO
COMBAT RUSSIA AFTER ITS INVASION
OF UKRAINE.
WE HAVE THE SAUDIS UPSET WITH US
AS WE'RE HELPING OUT IRAN.
WE'VE CUT OFF OUR OWN ENERGY
SUPPLIES AND ENERGY PRODUCTION.
WE'RE ON HANDS AND KNEES BEGGING
FOR OIL FROM DICTATORS AND SAUDI
ARABIA AND IT'S NOT GOING WELL.
IT'S A COMPLETE AND UTTER
DISASTER AND WE'RE NOT EVEN
HAPPENING WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
CHINA'S CONTINUED RISE, NORTH
KOREA'S AGGRESSION.
>> NO QUESTION GOING TO
VENEZUELA.
>> Laura: NOW HAT IN HAND TO
VENEZUELA IN THE PRISONER SWAP,
THE TIMING IS, BUT THE PRISONER
SWAP IS ANOTHER ISSUE.
I HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT THE
PRESS, MOLLIE AND I HAVE CHEWED
THIS OVER BEFORE BUT YOU WERE
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY.
HOW MUCH DAMAGE HAS THE AMERICAN
MEDIA COMPLEX DONE TO ITSELF
GIVEN WHAT'S HAPPENED TO THE
COUNTRY IN UNDER TWO YEARS
WITHOUT REALLY PUSHING BACK AND
DEMANDING ACCOUNTABILITY?
>> IRREPARABLE.
THE AMOUNT OF DAMAGE THE MEDIA
HAS DONE TO THIS COUNTRY, NOT
JUST DIVIDING US BUT NOT DOING
THE JOB AND ASKING THE QUESTIONS
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE
ANSWERS TO, IT IS SO EGREGIOUS
AT THIS POINT.
THERE'S A REASON THAT THE
MEDIA'S POPULARITY SITS
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN CONGRESS AND
COVID.
IT'S BECAUSE THEY REFUSE TO DO
THEIR JOBS AND ASK SIMPLE
QUESTIONS THAT ANYONE CAN ASK.
AND, BY THE WAY, IF YOU PUSH
BACK ON THEIR NARRATIVE -- I
MEAN, LOOK, DEMOCRATS CONTROL
ALL THE LEVERS OF POWER
INFLUENCE, COLLEGES, UNIVERSITY,
BIG TECH, HOLLYWOOD AND THE MAIN
STREAM MEDIA.
THEY'VE GOT IT ALL.
AND ANY THREAT TO THAT, YOU SEE
SOMEONE LIKE ELON MUSK TRYING TO
TAKE OVER TWITTER, THAT THREAT
CAUSES --
>> Laura: OH, CONSTERNATION.
>> IT'S INSANE.
>> Laura: HOW ABOUT THAT POOR
REPORTER FROM NBC ASKED
FETTERMAN AND SAVANNAH GUTHRY
COMES DOWN ON THAT REPORTER LIKE
SHE'S JUST COMMITTED SOME HATE
CRIME.
>> WELL, IT WAS VERY WEIRD TO
SEE A REPORTER REPORT PROBLEMS
ON THE DEMOCRATS SO EVERYONE WAS
UNNERVED BY IT BUT IT SHOWS WHY
CORPORATE MEDIA ARE SO UNABLE TO
BE TRUSTED AND NO ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR EVERYTHING THEY GET WRONG
WHETHER IT'S THE RUSSIA
COLLUSION HOAX THAT'S UNRAVELING
AND NO ONE'S HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR ALL THESE THINGS.
>> THAT'S THE BIGGEST PROBLE